they watch tucker the same way i watch
the drew barrymore show first time for
fun
second to figure out how she can
possibly successfully pull off a segment
in which a child
makes a shirley temple while stanley
tucci quietly drinks an entire glass of
wine on a screen in the background
i don't know how you work your magic
drew but i want to learn you're
advancing this form
hello everyone we're gonna make a drink
called the john
oliver here with the shirley temple king
himself it's leo kelly
hi everybody thank you for having me on
this is great
i love doing this with you so fun okay
so in
honor of john oliver i know let's make
the john
oliver shirley temple shirley temple
so we're going to take some seltzer
sprite ginger oil whatever you want to
use
what's your favorite leo i like ginger
ale perfect
what now we're gonna take some grenadine
you know the drill just a basic chili
temple but wait
there's more there is in honor of john
oliver we're gonna add a
[Music]
olive wait what if we added one of each
color
oh yes we have a kalamala kalamata
and uh greenish yeah exactly that's what
i was gonna call it too
there's like an olive called like the
castella vatrana i can't even say it
okay
this is the john oliver shirley temple
cheers cheers that's an honor of you
john oliver no i don't like olives but
as long as it's for
john olive will add all of
to the shirley temple in honor of john
oliver
man you're getting some great puns on
this show
you said be punny and funny yes that
should be
uh a sighting on the show it's pony and
funny
it's pretty funny that's how we advance
the form john oliver
it's funny and funny we love you john
[Music]
oliver
you